[Music]
on this Friday night a litany of charges
in the Rideau Hall security breach he
had several weapons new details on the
accused intruder and how long it took
for police to arrest him the
controversial contract between the feds
and the wee charity cancelled the ethics
commissioner's pending investigation
Atlanta Canadians now free to roam four
provinces who wants to burst this travel
bubble and when Co vid crashes the
greatest outdoor show on earth we wanted
to celebrate it in some way how to party
Calgary Stampede style during the
pandemic
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
reporting tonight David Aken good
evening and thank you for joining us we
are learning more tonight about the
security breach near the Prime
Minister's residence and the alleged
suspect involved a Manitoba man who is a
member of the military is facing several
weapons related charges he was arrested
yesterday morning police say he managed
to get less than 200 meters from the
prime minister's front door Abigail
Beeman has our top story tonight a new
barrier at the gate of Rideau Hall the
morning after this Dodge Ram rammed it
open immediate measures have been put in
place to increase security following
yesterday's events but the RCMP aren't
saying much about those events or the
motivation of the suspect identified as
46 year old Corey huran police did
release more information on the to our
timeline alleging her and drove into the
gate at 6:29 a.m. left the truck here
and hid near the bushes all the way over
here
an officer spoke to him by the green
house at 6:45 but it took 8 minutes
before he responded and another hour and
a half before he was arrested he had
several weapons her and now faces 22
charges most relating to weapons with
one count of uttering threats who that
business to something incredible you
know certainly his clients don't matter
Toba that Norman he sells his products
to this is not the kind of guy that
shows up in Ottawa with a gun bill gayde
runs the local radio station in Swan
River he launched this go fund me page
to raise money for the hirin family he
says the tight-knit community has been
hit hard by the news with many different
opinions on what happened and a lot of
shock hirin is a Canadian Ranger he
built a Meat Company which in am a
Facebook post he says kovat 19 forced
him to put on hold the manager of the
Swan Valley co-op said huran also worked
there for 11 years until he quit in 2019
and they'll cooperate with any
authorities in an investigation that's
not corey that's not the way he's ever
act he's always done good for the
community he
remember the Lions Club he's done
amazing things for them Friday's court
appearance was very brief her and will
remain in custody until his next court
date July 17th david abigail Beeman in
Ottawa Thank You Abigail in Winnipeg a
14 year old boy has been charged with
first degree murder
that happened after a string of
shootings that left one person dead and
several others injured police say the
crimes appear to be random the teen
cannot be named under the Youth Criminal
Justice Act
he's accused of a series of shootings
and assaults over a 24 hour period that
started early Wednesday morning one of
the victims a 27 year old woman died
police say none of the victims were
known to the suspect we don't believe
any of these victims knew their shooter
and that's about as far as we can get in
terms of motive at this time and I think
that's an important component to this
investigation I think it's going to be
terrifying and concerning for a lot of
Winnipeg the fact that we would have so
much violence and committed by such a
young individual the 14 year old remains
in custody facing multiple charges
police say he had no prior criminal
record Parliament's ethics commissioner
wants to know more about Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau's ties to the we charity
we had been tapped by the Trudeau
government to distribute 900 million
dollars in honorariums to tens of
thousands of students for volunteer work
today though the prime minister said the
deal with we had been scrapped Robin
Gill is hosting the West block this
weekend and joins us now so Robin what
is behind this wee controversy David
from the beginning the Prime Minister
insisted that this wasn't a conflict of
interest giving we this contract even
though his wife is an ambassador to the
organisation
Sophie Gregoire Trudeau is often front
and center at wee events here she is in
London just in March before she tested
positive for Kovan 19 the charity
founded by Canadian brothers Mark and
Craig Kielburger was supposed to manage
the federal government's 900 million
dollar program to pay students and new
graduates who volunteered this summer
each volunteer could get up to five
thousand dollars for schooling costs if
they work the maximum 500 hours in a
statement all youth Minister barters
chugger would say is that it was a
mutually agreed upon decision but the
Prime Minister says it was the charity
that decided to back out obviously we're
going to continue to work to ensure that
young people have opportunities to serve
right across the country this is
something that will change a bit with
Wiis decision which we support we will
continue to work very hard and we need
to reflect carefully on what exactly
went wrong and how we can make sure that
we're doing a better job of supporting
young people in the coming coming months
and years from the outset the Prime
Minister said the public service made
the decision to give we the contract now
that very same public service will have
to run the program the opposition
parties have demanded to know how much
the charity's stood to gain from
administering the program NDP leader
Doug meets Inc tweeted this doesn't
clear up why and how the decision was
made in the first place the Prime
Minister still needs to answer for this
scandal the opposition parties are not
letting up the Conservatives have even
gone as far to the Auditor General to
launch an investigation as for we the
charity organisation it'll now have to
pay back the federal government all the
money it's been given so far David Robin
Gill in Vancouver tonight thank you very
much Robin and Alberta first nation east
of Calgary is working overtime to deal
with an outbreak of Cova 19 imposing new
restrictions to contain the cluster the
Siksika First Nation has recorded 10
cases of Govan 19 and there's now
concern there could be more the First
Nations chief says the risk of community
transmission is high in Atlantic Canada
Kovan 19 infection rates remain
relatively low and stay
Abell there are just five active cases
in the entire region their success is
paying off in a big way today all four
Atlantic provinces are opening up their
borders to each other as Eric Sorenson
explains it's a turning point in the
pandemic finally the confederation
bridge is connecting Prince Edward
Island errs to New Brunswickers once
more this couple from Pei on their way
to see grandchildren in Fredericton
great feel great little freedom not far
away a simple drive from Nova Scotia to
New Brunswick became a breakthrough
achievement the huge numbers traveling
and the patience required a reminder of
how covert 19 has smothered life as we
know it for the last four months about
30 minutes there are checkpoints
entering all four provinces slowing
things down but not dampening spirits oh
it feels pretty good we just had some
paperwork completed and that we did
which was really quite easy and quite
efficient
until now the four Atlantic provinces
have been in their own bubbles and it
has worked by and large the numbers in
Atlantic Canada fewer than 1,600 total
cases over the last four months that
represents 1.4 percent of the national
total of more than a hundred thousand
cases as for new cases in Nova Scotia
there were two on July the second and
the other three Atlantic provinces there
were none but as you go from individual
bubbles to one big bubble does that risk
increasing the spread of kovat 19 the
more people cross paths with one another
the greater the chance the virus will
develop in Newfoundland and Labrador
some are worried about 15,000 signed an
online petition that says the provinces
slowly going back to normal and it reads
we want to keep it that way
this is not the time to open the borders
this epidemiologist says it's a
calculated but reasonable risk to reopen
and it's an essential kickstart for
tourism and the Atlantic economy says
one mayor the risk of illness from the
virus directly has to be weighed against
the stresses and the difficulties
created by financial hardships and the
social isolation it may look like
gridlock but it's a happy day New
Brunswickers going one way Nova Scotians
the other and the hope that Atlantic
Canada never has to lock down again
Erick Sorenson global news shifting now
to a very different situation in the
United States with infection numbers
surging many states are reversing course
on reopening plans as they struggle to
get the virus under control in some
areas so many people are needing tests
that labs cannot keep up as Jackson
prosecco reports there are fears that
soon hospitals will also be totally
overwhelmed backed into the corner by
the virus America is locking back down
there's now a curfew in Miami in place
indefinitely until the pandemic is
brought under control Texas implemented
a statewide mask order Koba 19 is not
going away in fact is getting worse
Chicago announced a mandatory quarantine
for anyone traveling from 15 hard-hit
states we are not going to suffer the
Fate that we've seen of other states and
localities across the country the surge
in case numbers is unlike anything so
far in Arizona nearly one in every four
kovat 19 tests has come back positive in
Florida which saw nearly 10,000 new
cases again on Friday it's one in every
five I'm incredibly worried about what's
happening we had hoped for a decline in
cases in order to deal with what might
be considered a second wave we haven't
even gotten out of this first wave and
it's getting worse now there's a new
problem testing sites like this one in
Arizona are overwhelmed Labs can't
process the crush of samples it's
absolutely the saddest thing the most
unnecessary situation that we're finding
ourselves in and it's behaviorally
driven the timing of the surge up
against the busy fourth of July holiday
couldn't be worse and federal leadership
has been virtually absent President
Donald Trump hit the links for a round
of golf Friday
before jetting off to watch fireworks at
Mount Rushmore in a crowd of thousands
with no social distancing the US Surgeon
General declined to say whether mass
gatherings like that should be avoided
it's not a yes-or-no every single person
has to make up their own mind
increasingly there's fear about what the
coming weeks will look like with
hospitals already nearing capacity and
with more death all but certain
the CDC admits 20,000 more Americans
could die in the next three weeks with
the virus now so widespread it can't be
contained
Jackson prosto Global News Washington
Canada is suspending an extradition
treaty with Hong Kong that comes after
China imposed a new controversial
security law on the region Ottawa is
also taking other steps to change the
way it deals with Hong Kong Canada will
treat exports of sensitive goods to Hong
Kong in the same way as those destined
from mainland China effective
immediately
Canada will not permit the export of
sensitive military items to Hong Kong
the new Chinese legislation criminalizes
virtually all forms of dissent it also
sets up Chinese law enforcement in Hong
Kong and allows anyone detained there to
be extradited to the Chinese mainland
roughly 300,000 Canadians live in Hong
Kong the former British colony
sovereignty was given back to China in
1997 but certain rights were supposed to
be guaranteed under the one country two
systems' agreement meanwhile a Hong Kong
man has become the first person charged
under the new security law the 23 year
old was arrested on Wednesday after
allegedly driving a motorcycle into
police during a protest he was carrying
a sign saying liberate Hong Kong he was
charged today with inciting separatism
and terrorism England is getting ready
for Super Saturday coming up the cheers
and jeers as pubs prepared to reel
tragedy has struck south east of
Edmonton where three people have died in
a plane crash the aircraft plummeted
into a field this morning according to
fire crews witnesses believe they heard
the small planes engine stall moments
before it crashed an official from the
cooking Lake Airport tells global news
that one of the victims was a flying
instructor the United Kingdom is still
one of the hot spots of covin 19 in
Europe but overall infection rates are
dropping and starting tomorrow
England's world-renowned pubs will
reopen as restrictions ease and today
Prince William got in early skipping the
queue to sip on his first pub pint and a
check how owners are preparing for the
influx of people as Redmond Shannon
reports while many are in desperate need
of a drink others are a little nervous
the UK's first pub pints in more than a
hundred days were poured in Northern
Ireland on Friday together but at least
we understand thiss Cove in nineteen
appears to be under control in much of
the UK but the English city of leicester
was forced back into a hard lockdown
this week after a spike in new
infections it comes as the rest of
England emerges from lockdown this
Saturday with pubs restaurants and hair
salons reopening we're not out of the
woods yet
Prime Minister Boris Johnson is pleading
with the public to behave the economic
health of the whole country is dependent
on every single one of us acting
responsibly given the chaotic scenes at
this English speech just last week many
people are worried about bars reopening
slightly worried about going into a pole
on public transport at the moment for me
I'm quite frightened yeah still for some
of the younger people it may be fine but
if it starts to spread we've got a real
problem
Britain's pubs are also not quite the
community hubs they once were a quarter
of them have closed down within the past
20 years the lockdown and this sanitized
new reality will only further impact an
industry and a tradition that was
already struggling and hopefully the
measures we've put in place are too
strict and restrictive so if customers
don't feel as though they can relax
enjoy themselves the future of the UK's
proud pop culture could hinge on these
next few months and the spread of the
virus will depend on how people behave
Redman Shannon Dublin News London
weeks after ending one of the world's
strictest lock downs South Africa is
seeing a surge in new kovat 19 cases
more than 80 700 new cases were reported
on Thursday that is the country's
biggest single day jump since the start
of the pandemic hospitals are now
bracing for a surge in patients
officials warn they may have to reimpose
restrictions to get infections under
control
still ahead why are hundreds of
elephants in Botswana suddenly died you
are watching global national
at least 22 people are dead after a
train hit a bus in eastern Pakistan
officials say the bus driver was trying
to cross the railway tracks but got
stuck as the train approached the bus
was reportedly filled with Sikh pilgrims
who were returning from a visit to a
shrine many of those killed or believed
to be from the same family a trial into
the grisly murder of Saudi journalist
Jamal kesaji
got underway in Turkey today the
defendants 20 Saudi nationals have all
left Turkey and are being tried in
absentia
because Shoji's fiance told the court
today that he was lured to his death
through a great betrayal and deception
Koosh OG was an outspoken critic of the
Saudi regime he was tortured killed and
dismembered inside Saudi Arabia's
consulate in Istanbul in October 2018
the defendants include two former aides
to Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman who denies involvement Saudi
Arabia convicted eight people over the
murder last year but they have never
been identified but SWANA is
investigating the mysterious deaths of
hundreds of elephants a warning some of
the video here may be upsetting the
country has confirmed 275 have died but
a rescue organization says the number
could be over four hundred the dead
elephants were first spotted months ago
in the popular okavango delta area
common killers like poaching and anthrax
have been ruled out samples are being
collected to figure out what is causing
these sudden deaths if this was a
disease or virus or bacteria outbreak
that was to spread and as I mentioned
earlier if those smaller less
genetically diverse populations were
affected then it could have devastating
consequences for the elephant population
and therefore the economy and the
environment of the host countries as
well a conservation group calls is quote
one of the biggest disasters to impact
elephants this century Africa's overall
elephant population is declining due to
poaching but Botswana home to almost 1/3
of the continents elephants has
seen a growth in the numbers since the
late 90s up next stampede in spirit how
a Calgary tradition is still saddling up
for the first time in a century the
Calgary Stampede has been sidelined
today was supposed to be parade day but
because of the Cova 19 pandemic much of
the greatest show on earth has been
canceled now is heather York's West
reports many in that city are finding
other ways to celebrate he was supposed
to be parade marshal instead Raziel born
Felipe machete let a completed an 8 year
journey crossing the Americas on
horseback with a quiet convoy across
Calgary still arriving at the Stampede
grounds marked the realization of a
lifelong dream because of the pandemic
there will be no parade Midway or rodeo
but across Calgary the Stampede spirit
is strong wanted to celebrate it in some
way and the thought was that we can just
bring Stampede to homes across Calgary
with our team of photographers the team
already capturing dozens of western
themed family snapshots they plan to
keep it going all of summer long for
Karla Cruz and Curtis bercovich it was
the perfect way to kick off a stampede
that will be spent for the most part at
home I can't think of a year where I
hadn't done something you know it's
unusual that it's not going on there
will be some official Stampede events on
offer there will be fireworks and food
just a little bit of a taste of Stampede
hopefully being offered through the the
pancake drive throughs the mini donut
Drive thrus and the food truck rally
while many Stampede corporate parties
have had to be canceled many companies
are still asking their employees to show
their Western pride by dressing up while
working from home
from social media pancake parties to
learning line dances online many
community celebrations have gone virtual
too so we thought let's offer something
online that people could join in and
still feel that sense of community and
connection for the die-hard it's a far
cry from the real thing but in a year
where nothing is normal
there's one thing that's certain
Stampede 2020 will be one that no one
forgets whether your ex West Global News
Calgary and that is global national for
this Friday I'm David akin tonight's
your Canada is this iceberg in port Rex
in Newfoundland and Labrador we love
seeing your Canada so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at global
national calm thank you for watching
Robin Gill will be here tomorrow good
night from the nation's capital
[Music]